today's conversation is with lynn alden
lynn alden is one of the best macro
analysts and has quickly become one of
my favorite voices in the bitcoin
community as well
in this conversation lynn and i discuss
everything from the federal reserve to
monetary and fiscal policy the debt
cycle bitcoin and where she sees the
world evolving to over the coming years
i really enjoyed this conversation and i
hope you guys enjoy it as well these
conversations are brought to you by ftx
you can learn more by clicking on the
link in the description let's get in
this episode with lynn and let me know
in the comments what you think about her
analysis and the conversation today
let's start with lynn uh lynn how are
you doing today
pretty good how are you i am doing very
well uh i'm looking forward to speaking
with you because i think you've got a
nuanced view on inflation
one of the maybe misconceptions about
inflation is that it is only driven by
monetary policy obviously monetary
policy has a big effect but you recently
wrote a piece about fiscal driven
inflation maybe you could expand on that
a little bit and explain why is the
fiscal component so important given the
inflation we're seeing right now
sure so a big theme i've had actually
for a couple years now is that the
inflation that we're going to get which
which now we have is in large part
driven by fiscal spending and the
difference you know for for people that
don't know the difference monetary
policy is like what the central bank
does it's like what are interest rates
going to be are they doing quantitative
easing or quantitative tightening that
sort of thing whereas fiscal policy uh
is that basically about taxing and
spending by uh you know congress and the
president um
and especially when you get extreme
fiscal policy uh like you know unusually
large multi-trillion dollar deficits um
that that actually puts money out of the
broad money supply and so if you look
back at say the 2008 crisis for example
um there was a large monetary response
so we saw the the base money go up quite
a bit but most most of that just stayed
in the banking system it didn't actually
really circulate to the general public
it's not like you and me got checks sent
to us uh that we can then use to buy
things right so there would it's not
like people had more purchasing power
there's there was not a realistic
version of more money chasing the same
goods whereas what we saw in the 2020
response uh was in addition to the
monetary response we also had things
like helicopter money um ppp loans that
turn into grants um you know uh tax
basically just tax cuts that are not uh
offset by
anything else
and so that was a large injection
directly to people's bank accounts in
different ways we also saw corporate
bailouts for example
and so in that type of environment you
actually have a broad money supply
increase there's actually more money
that people can control
chasing the same number of goods and
services and of course the monetary
policy is still relevant because they're
putting money to buy the bonds that is
enabling the physical expenditure uh
because if they try to just issue
trillion dollars of bonds um they'd have
problems with like liquidity like there
wouldn't be enough buyers showing up to
buy those treasuries
and so the the central banks are
monetizing that fiscal um so it's really
that that blend of monetary policy and
physical together as well as of course
real world constraints that we've run
into right so the fact that we had under
invested in you know kind of physical
goods like you know oil capex and things
like that for a few years was it was the
also the supply side of this whole
inflation thing is it fair to break down
the most simplistic uh analysis being
monetary policy drives liquidity into
the financial system but fiscal policy
drives liquidity into the hands of
people and because we got both in 2020
the monetary policy drove the asset
bubble and the fiscal policy drove the
inflation so kind of all
items went up in price some of them were
investment assets some of them were
consumer goods and services is that a
way to break it down or could the fiscal
policy actually have also had an impact
on the asset prices going up as well
i think you described it well but i
would say that that fiscal impacts both
so i think that i think that monetary
policy you know specifically qe putting
putting liquidity into the system is is
generally pretty good for financial
assets uh whereas uh fiscal policy is is
is basically you know consumer price
inflation uh as well as you know because
that consumer price inflation resulting
in more revenue and and things like that
for various businesses at least in
nominal terms um it's also generally
good for asset prices and nominal terms
um whether it's in real terms is another
story and a good example of this is is
japan because if you look at their qe i
mean they did more qe as a percentage of
their gdp than like any other major
country i mean they have you know their
balance sheets over 100 percent of their
gdp whereas united states it's like you
know under 40 percent and they just it
looks like a weimar chart if you look at
their at their base money but because it
wasn't combined with huge fiscal
expenditures i mean their their broad
money supply actually went up pretty
slowly this whole time and if you look
at japan so they they're well known for
like their 30-year bear market where
their equities are still literally like
cheaper than they were
in the beginning of the 90s
but that wasn't like a sideways market i
mean you had a a couple decades of
downturn and then starting around 2012
you japan actually had a pretty strong
equity bull market it was like one of
the you know outside of the us it was
one of the better performing equity
markets over the past decade and that's
that's specifically when their qe
started really ramping up uh in 2012
they started printing a ton of money in
2012 they never really stopped and that
included for them unlike the fed buying
equities and so if you look at japanese
equities from 2012 you look at their qe
from 2012 there's a pretty strong
correlation with that being very good
for their equity market
but it wasn't consumer price
inflationary for japan because again it
wasn't combined with things like
helicopter money or things like that
when most people look at high inflation
in the united states like we're
experiencing now they point to the 1970s
your analysis for a while now has been
rooted in not comparing current
environments 1970s but rather the 1940s
can you elaborate a little bit on what
was going on in the 40s that makes it a
much more attractive comparison in your
mind
sure so in the 1970s a lot of the
inflation that we had was from bank
loans right so there were fiscal
deficits uh but they weren't the biggest
driver of what we're having there was a
demographics boom so right so there was
like you know the boomers were going
into their home buying years um and so
there's this rapid increase in demand
for things
and so that you had a pretty significant
money supply growth but that was because
a lot of banks were lending money into
existence and then of course you threw
on top of that um you know the guns and
butter programs you threw on some fiscal
deficits on top of that
and uh you know that was combined with
the fact that the one similarity the key
similar to the 70s is that we had an
energy supply problem so so u.s oil
production peaked in 1970 after like 100
years of like constantly going up and so
we became more reliant on the middle
east um and so we obviously had some
some geopolitical turmoils with that and
trouble getting the oil supply we need
up against a time of a very huge demand
that was largely demographics and bank
loan driven
whereas if you go back to the 40s the
reason that's more similar is because
that inflation was not driven by bank
lending uh banks weren't really lending
a ton during that era instead that was
driven by massive fiscal expenditures
and so you know the 1930s you know were
a lot like the 2010s in the sense that
you know the 1929 crash and the 2008
crash were pretty similar you had a
gigantic private debt bubble blowing up
they had this long period of stagnation
rising populism uh kind of just rising
economic fragility and then in the 1940s
they were hit with external shock
basically that populism had spread
around the world you got you got you
know these wars starting to materialize
and so they had to do you know they did
large physical expenditures and a lot of
that was in the domestic economy they
were building you know manufacturing
facilities they were hiring people uh
when the when the soldiers came back
they they sent eight million of them
into technical school in college and
then helped them get out get a mortgage
um these were very large fiscal
expenditures and so you had a huge
increase in the in the money supply and
that was as you'd expect pretty
inflationary um and then the also the
key difference is so in the 70s
debt as a percentage of gdp both public
and private was pretty low and so when
they encountered inflation they could
raise rates to double digit levels to
try to quell inflation and give positive
real rates whereas the 1940s
because you had so much physical
expenditure to fight the war you had
over 100 percent debt the gdp and so
they couldn't really raise rates to to
match inflation levels and so they just
let it run hot and you had the biggest
ever gap between inflation uh and
interest rates uh and in fact they even
they even pegged the long end of the
treasury curve like what japan's doing
now and so this environment here in the
2020s i think is pretty similar because
one the growth of the money supply is
largely a physical phenomenon it's not
due to unusually high bank lending it's
due to an usually large physical
deficits that are monetized by the fed
which again actually they did that back
in the 40s so there's there's huge qe in
the 40s to monetize it and
it's not due to excessive demand or you
know
positive demographics
it's due to that that more strained
geopolitical environment and that
strained economic and socio-economic
environment you mentioned populism and
its relationship with fiscal policy
obviously social media has made it much
easier for people to communicate around
the world uh and it feels like every day
there's some new thing that people are
upset about or kind of you know cancer
culture is running wild or there's
virtue signaling going on uh and
obviously politicians are not immune to
getting caught up in kind of the whims
of uh the flavor of the day if you will
how much do you think uh the expansion
of fiscal policy that we've seen is just
there's an easier way for folks to
communicate they can tweet at
politicians they can make their voices
heard they've got podcasts and youtube
and kind of all these different
platforms and that means that
politicians now are more likely to kind
of hear the people and that leads to
kind of bigger and bigger and more
severe and aggressive uh fiscal policy
um kind of programs
i think it's a combination of that and
one of and then the debt so the debt
portion is the fact that when debt is
super high when you're hundreds of
percent like so in united states we have
370 percent public and private debt as a
percentage of gdp so if you if you had
corporate debt household debt and and
public debt combined it's you know 370
percent of gdp or so and that's that's
basically unpayable in real terms and so
the question becomes how does that
default does that default uh nominally
probably not because the liabilities are
in our own currency and so instead you
generally are going to get default
through inflation uh where you're just
going to have a long period of negative
real rates and so those bond holders
will get paid back but not necess you
know not not in real terms and so large
fiscal expenditures while holding rates
low are one of the the main ways to
inflate away uh large levels of debt so
i think that's that's the mathematical
component and then the the the more
social
component is that populism and generally
you know that kind of goes back to the
fourth turning concept of you know
people people build these institutions
and those institutions last for decades
um but then over time you know as the
founders that they die and as you get
kind of the third fourth generation of
these institutions
they drift away from their original
purpose or they become corrupted or
society has changed and no longer
respects those institutions usually a
combination of all these things together
and so in that period of rising populism
they generally feel that the
institutions the frameworks that we've
constructed are no longer
working well for the majority of the
people and so you start to get a lot of
pushbacks on it that could be the
government that can be media that can be
uh certain corporations basically uh you
know certain international organizations
and when you start to get that pushback
on that you get this broad distrust of
that sort of thing and you have just
kind of like that very fragile system
from how much debt's there and so i i
think in that when they're hit by an
external shock uh i think they err on
the side of basically money printing
because in their mind it's better than
debt collapse and so generally when you
get the end of a long-term debt cycle
like we're at now
it tends to die and fire rather than ice
meaning that you tend to err on the side
of high inflation rather than
deflationary collapse you mentioned both
public and private debt what's the
relationship between those two and how
do we kind of go back and forth between
having more public debt or more private
debt and is it important to watch kind
of the percentages or the balance
between public and private or do you
just analyze it all as one big bucket of
debt
i think they're very different uh and
it's because private debt is actually
more deflationary um uh because if you
start to default uh and you don't pay
loans back or you know things like that
that actually destroys broad money um
and so both of the biggest private debt
bubble collapses in american history uh
which would be you know the 1929
aftermath you know into the 30s and the
2008 aftermath in the into the 2010s um
both of those were pretty
disinflationary periods um
and the general theme the same thing for
japan right so their their 19 uh you
know late late 1980s uh debt bubble
basically spent then decades just like
melting uh as as that you know private
debt bubble kind of just worked itself
out and a general theme is that private
debt bubbles
slowly get resolved by pushing that up
to the public level right so so
generally a private debt bubble precedes
a public debt bubble and then as that
private debt bubble is kind of melting
and people are getting all disgruntled
that's usually when you when they come
in with larger fiscal deficits um they
do very simplists and what eventually
happens is that private debt bubble kind
of diminishes but then shows up on the
public balance sheet so larger
sovereign debt relative to gdp
and that tends to be more inflationary
because that that is never going to be
defaulted on because it's in their own
liabilities and and so that's where it
eventually gets expressed through the
currency uh you busy the only way the
only way that that debt gets discharged
uh is by you know currency devaluation
and basically defaulting in real terms
and so we saw that in japan right so you
had that gigantic absolutely huge
private debt bubble
spends decade melting uh run persistent
uh moderate deficits that are constantly
being monetized and instead you know
we've had actually deleveraging for
example in japanese corporations but all
that debt is now on in you know japanese
government debt and then we saw the same
thing uh in the you know us 1930s and
40s and we saw the same thing in the u.s
you know 2010 to 2020. so now we're in
more of the public debt bubble phase of
this which tends to be more inflationary
period
when we look at
the last i don't know two years one of
the things that sticks out around the
central bank is that the federal reserve
was holding interest rates artificially
low at zero percent uh and they also
were conducting quantitative easing even
though inflation in the summer of 2021
got over five percent and by the end of
the year was over seven percent what is
the importance of realizing in hindsight
that that probably was a mistake
is it something that you can kind of
ascribe uh a level of uh severity in
terms of the problem we're experiencing
now
uh or how do you kind of analyze that
action like that's such a crazy thing in
hindsight that they were still doing
that how do you look at it
one of the the challenges i find is
determining what is a mistake and what
is intentional right so
if they know that they're super high
debt levels and the only way to
discharge them is through inflation um
you could make an argument that it was a
mistake um whereas
it's kind of like are they smart but
then being misleading or are they
actually dumb right so it's kind of like
one or the other um there was a black
rock paper written in 2019 before the
the pandemic and it was like you know
the next downturn monetary policy is not
going to be enough because interest
rates are so low and debts are so high
so we're going to have to do significant
fiscal stimulus
but that can be inflationary and drive
rates up so they're going to have to
keep rates low through monetary policy
so you're going to have to have
coordination between fiscal monetary
policy but then the challenge is that
that can cause runaway inflation so
that's going to be managed very
carefully so they actually kind of laid
out the whole playbook at a time and and
that was both blackrock and it was it
was advised by stanley fischer former
former fed official and of course they
didn't predict a pandemic but so it's
kind of even bigger than that paper
would have suggested but we actually
followed that playbook almost step by
step in terms of watching what these
policymakers are doing um and so
you know i think that they
they over they certainly overdid it i
think even in their view i think that
par i think part of the original one
they wanted to let it run hot for my
first reason that they wanted to burn
some dead away but i didn't think that
they did they thought it would get this
hot this quickly um and i think if they
did they probably would have done
certain things differently and i think
it's because a lot of their models are
just not not great i don't i don't think
they're looking at at oil catbacks the
real world supply side stuff and i also
don't think they're making a great
distinction between broad my supply and
base money supply as its impact on
inflation i just think that a lot of
their models are out of date and that
the models are kind of bureaucratic i
mean they're they're these large
institutions a lot of academic input
and i don't i don't think they have like
the the rapid learning effect that you
see more in like the business world
when we think about this inflation i
want to talk about two specific
contributions so we're talking about the
data and how they didn't think that
inflation would get this hot this
quickly the first one is what i'll call
kind of external events so obviously the
pandemic is one that you mentioned
there's also been supply chain
disruptions that have kind of come in
the wake of that there's been
geopolitical conflict with russia's
invasion of ukraine how do you
anticipate them uh either trying to uh
see these events coming to analyze them
in real time like how much of an impact
do these external events have on
changing their policy or is it something
where they just have their policy
they're going to execute their plan and
although these things happen they don't
really either pay attention or they end
up not actually being willing to change
the plan uh regardless of what happens
externally
i think these external things eventually
change their plan especially as
expressed through markets um and so the
fed has to kind of put out fires as they
come
and so these events kind of you know
end up showing up in markets which then
ends up having to be the things that the
fed ass respond to so for example they
you know in 1919 i bet none of them
expected what they'd be doing in 2020 at
the scale they were doing it at and so
they had to you know i mean they had an
emergency meeting in march 2020 and they
were kind of changing their plan because
the treasury market broke which i don't
think was on like you know their 2019
bingo cards um i think you know things
like what we're seeing due politically
it's challenging because
it's like
it becomes self-referential usually um
you know the the problems like when you
have long-term debt cycles blowing up
and then you have more inflationary
periods that leads to more discontent
and more geopolitical struggle which
then leads to more inflation and and so
it's kind of that vicious cycle uh
that's generally what you see in these
periods and so one leads to the other
one leads back to itself um
and you know when it comes to for
example what we're seeing in in say you
know ukraine
europe's energy prices so natural gas
prices in europe which
which if anyone has looked at them they
look like a weimar chart it's like it's
a horrifying price chart as you know
compared to what we're what we're
experiencing in the united states in
terms of energy prices so no natural gas
prices soared but that happened in late
2021 they were already encountering
challenges with that and then you know
the whole russian invasion just added
more problems on top of that it didn't
create the problem initially it just
added layers of additional risks and
insecurity and additional volatility and
inflation on top of what was already
you know a physical constraint in terms
of natural gas and and other things that
were happening there and so i think
that's gonna be the theme of the 2020s
is basically problems feeding back on on
making the problems even worse
the second piece is the data they're
actually looking at so you mentioned the
models are outdated maybe even
bureaucratic to some degree uh there's
now been what i'll consider public
conversation or mainstream conversation
around just how the data is collected
there's been articles that show hey they
only have a couple hundred people that
literally physically go to the store
with a tablet and they're like manually
inputting prices uh you can look at
something like the cpi
rent methodology where they're
essentially using outdated census data
to call people on the phone
and really where this gets highlighted
is we have companies like square or
zillow or apartment.com and you know
various other what i would consider more
real-time uh much more robust data sets
how do you evaluate the uh maybe
accuracy of the data they have uh and
then how do you compare it to other data
sets that are out there that they may
just be ignoring or they don't want to
use
how do you kind of evaluate it
basically i do what you just said i look
at i look at what the public you know
models are doing so i look at what
official cpi is doing because of course
that's a lot of traditional markets like
the bond market will look at things like
that so they're relevant to know and to
understand what's happening in that data
but then i also do go out to you know to
things like like these real-time rent
indicators and things like that
and it's a couple of things one is it
helps you determine the accuracy or the
inaccuracy of things like cpi two is it
lets you predict what's going to happen
with cpi so one of the reasons i was
expecting cpi to go up is because i saw
the rent
component happening in real time and i
was like this is going to start showing
up in cpi because because cpi kind of
incorporates that over time but like
with a lag and smoothed out and and you
know somewhat inaccurate but it still
ends up getting into there uh in a
pretty significant way and so i think
that looking at
that mix of things uh is super important
because the the the you know the
government statistics are important for
traditional markets responding to them
um and and knowing how policymakers
gonna try to respond to them and how
they're going to signal around that but
then yeah those real world faster time
updating ones are super useful for for
accuracy there's also things like you
know there's
uh services that track what used car
prices are doing it comes out you know
every couple weeks instead of you know
with a lag and it's in my view pretty
accurate and like you said there's
really good rent indicators um things
like that
as we moved into 2022 kind of at the end
of 2021 we started to see the fed talk
tough and then they actually started to
act in 2022 uh and the overarching theme
is basically destroyed demand they keep
using that uh phrase destroy demand
destroyed demand uh they now have done a
number of aggressive uh interest rate
hikes uh they also have stated that they
are going to do quantitative
tightening how effective can they be in
destroying demand and maybe even what
does that mean in terms of the
experience for everyday americans or
financial institutions if the fed says
they're going to destroy demand what
exactly does that entail and then how
effective can they be
so i think they could be effective in
the near term and i think to some extent
they already have been uh they
contributed to the housing market
seizing up for example uh if basically
if you make financing costs a lot higher
uh that does impact cap companies
ability to get capital uh consumers
ability to get capital uh you know to
borrow things to buy assets and and to
buy other things um
and you know there's also like a wealth
effect right so going into this uh
period
u.s household net worth was six times as
high as gdp
um you know it got up to four and a half
during the dot-com bubble it got about
the same height during the 2007 housing
bubble uh but going into this period it
was six it was six times and so when you
you know the fed is able to put downward
pressure on asset prices by doing things
like ending qe doing some mild qt trying
to raise rates uh period of time
and if people see their asset prices
going down pretty quickly that can also
change their discretionary spending
levels and so i think a lot of these
things combined do impact demand in the
near term but the problem is that
because the economy is so financialized
because of so much debt in the system
and because the supply side is not
really being fixed especially look at
the at the energy component of that
specifically um
it's kind of short-sighted in the in the
longer term um the basically the only
way out of this is is improving the
supply side um
and so i you know again if you go back
to does the fed not know or do they know
but they're signaling differently um
and so if they're fighting this like the
1970s i think that's an error i think
instead they have to they have to be
aware that in many ways it's more like
the 1940s um and so 1970s attempts are
likely to backfire and
uh just this lead to more pain ahead i
think it's gonna be a i think we're
gonna have
this inflation issue i think is gonna be
something that that reoccurs uh for a
period of time
famed economist milton friedman uh has
said you know for years uh that
sometimes the government solution is
actually worse than the problem itself
uh if the fed is treating this like a
1970s situation and that is an error in
their policy what would the
ramifications or impact be what would
you expect the problem then to become
i think that they can cause a recession
and then
you know you start to get problems
instead of the treasury market or things
like that and then they have to reverse
course
and then it damages their credibility
and then they basically
ironically by tightening they can impact
the supply side they can make it harder
bring on new supplies of things that are
you know short and contributing to
inflation and then therefore they can
lead to even another inflation spike
when they eventually have to reverse and
turn dovish again um i think it i think
the problem itself goes back to the root
of price controls i don't think that
they should be doing price controls and
you know if you ask most people should
they should they be doing price controls
and people would say no but that's
essentially what the purpose of a
central bank is they do price controls
on the price of money um and so you're
kind of in a period of perpetual price
controls and so of course the question
is if they set the price at the wrong
level either too high or too low
that has huge ramifications um and so i
think it's
the deeper question is kind of like
should should central banking in its
current form even exist but the the near
term problem i think is that as you as
you get to the end of a long-term debt
cycle so as you get to lower lower
interest rates the higher and higher
debt as a percentage of gdp and higher
higher asset valuations as a percentage
of gdp you've really financialized the
economy and then there's no clean way
out right so i often
ascribe you know
the problems that they have now are
somewhat less about what they're you
know what they're doing right now right
so i'm not like i'm blaming powell for
all this inflation it's it's it's
decades of of kind of policy compounding
and then here there's there's
it's just it becomes a series of bad
decisions right are you going to choose
one bad outcome
or you're going to choose another bad
outcome because they've already kind of
painted themselves into a policy corner
we're recording this uh at the end of
july of 2022 uh and the fed has already
been uh conducting a number of actions
to create these tighter financial
conditions uh we're
in a year where there'll be midterm
elections
and i think most people have given up on
the idea of this soft landing
how likely is it that they can continue
in the direction that they are without
pivoting or kind of waving the white
flag through the end of this year
and then how likely do you think it is
that there would be some change of uh
kind of strategy before the end of 2023
like what is your expectations of you
know can they break something in the
short term is it gonna be more of a
medium term
what do you expect them to do over the
coming months and years
so i think by late this year or by early
next year they probably would have would
have pivoted their policy to some extent
um especially post-midterms um you know
right now for example you know they're
releasing the the strategic petroleum
reserve uh that's obviously a finite
thing that they can only do up to about
the election and it's something that
they can't keep doing after that
so that that i mean that's not a policy
that's a physical side that's that's not
a monetary side in terms of monetary
tightening i think that you know they
can tighten until one of a handful
things happen either the treasury market
goes a liquid like it did in march 2020
or
credits or repo markets encounter
problems
or you start to get
a severe labor weakness
with unemployment going up you know uh
you know say 100 basis points compared
to it is now um and i think those are
kind of the three the three things that
could really cause them to to have to
pivot i i would certainly expect that to
happen before late 2023 and and
potentially by late 2022.
one of the statistics that i saw
recently was uh it's like 80
of countries around the world are
experiencing high levels of inflation uh
or or materially higher than they uh
historically have how much of this is a
u.s problem versus just the entire world
is suffering at the hands of supply
chain disruptions geopolitical conflict
fallout and kind of other issues
so high debt levels
and that whole idea of having deflate
and dead away are a theme throughout
most developed markets so the united
states japan and europe at this point
so that's that's global at least for for
the the huge areas of global capital and
then commodities are a global market and
so if you have years of under investment
in energy capex that becomes a global
problem and then it becomes an issue of
kind of game theory because let's say
the united states for example prints a
ton of money um and gives it to people
and those people can go out and buy
things and consume energy
if there's another country that did not
print money their energy prices are
going to go up too
because the americans printed
and so
it becomes a global thing pretty quickly
so it spreads around because these
economies are so interlinked both in
terms of their debt similarities um
their financial connections as well as
the fact that the global commodity
pricing is a is a global supply and
demand market so we saw uh earlier this
year the ecb kind of broke from the
federal reserve uh in the interest rate
uh kind of actions they then capitulated
and started to follow how much emphasis
do you place on the difference of
strategy between kind of individual
central banks versus this debt load ends
up you know over the long term they're
all going to have to inflate it away and
so they may be able to hold out for
short periods of time but the kind of
longer term trend just outweighs
everything that they're doing the short
term
so i think the longer term trend is that
all of these countries that have well
over 100 percent public debt to gdp um
are going to be inflating that away uh
over a period of time but it does become
a question of is it is it disorderly or
is it orderly uh what is the order um
you know does one have to kind of go
first does one have less room to kick
the king down the road than another
those become relevant questions um i i
think i mean the ecb is in the most
challenging spot because they have a
more acute energy crisis uh than most
other developed market areas
and they have a monetary union without a
fiscal union right meaning that they set
monetary policy for the eurozone the ecb
does
but
individual countries have have you know
significant control over their own
fiscal policies more than for example
u.s states um and so
that kind of fragmentation
is just a it's a really challenging uh
environment to operate in uh and then
you know you have countries like italy
with 150 debt to gdp
so they need assistance monetizing their
sovereign debt um but then you have
other countries that are like wait why
are we doing that what you know why
can't we you know that that's not fair
for example um and so the ecb is just
you know just there's more moving levers
there that can go wrong um compared to
the united states and then even compared
to japan in my view um so i think that
there are some differences but they also
have the same general theme of too much
debt so it's not going to be fully paid
back in real terms over the long run
one of my favorite books is the dow of
capital uh by mark spitznagel
and one of the key themes in that book
is basically human intervention in
markets ends up throwing the market off
right a very kind of austrian view of
the world how
valid is that perspective given what
we've seen just even over the last two
years of kind of we went from a pandemic
to asset bubble high inflation now we're
kind of going the other way and it's
very obvious that this is being driven
by human uh kind of central bank led uh
intervention
does that just validate the austrian
view of the world and say hey look maybe
we should stop doing this
i think partially but i also think that
in terms of just reality governance is a
vacuum so governance feels
you know we're we're governed where
centralization does not exist it tends
to move in that direction um
one way i've been describing this this
whole era meaning going back 150
years is the it's mostly a technological
shortcoming right so because the speed
of commerce due to telecommunications
channels you know starting with like
laying undersea cables in the in the
late 1800s
and going from there um
that basically allowed commerce to occur
very quickly whereas bearer asset money
was slow and so it got abstracted
centralized arbitraged um and and so
just became inherently centralized and
controlled and political uh and so
i think that that it's understandable
that people are angry that phenomenon
but in some ways it's the order
technology made that almost inevitable
and it's not a surprise that we saw that
that model spread to like every country
in the world um and so i think it's more
constructive to focus on technological
solutions that can they can provide
alternatives like if someone doesn't
have an alternative other than you
shouldn't do this
but the natural incentives are for
people to do it then it's just you're
gonna kind of like be shouting into the
wind and so i i do think it's true that
you know when you have centralized pools
of power
and they're human and they're you know
they have human levels of bandwidth
dealing with uh something that's more
complex than any of us can realize
billions of you know weekly transactions
for example that there's inevitably
going to be errors um and the longer
term i think it's about finding ways of
of using technology to to decentralize
things i think you know we might finally
be at a point where we have technology
that allows us to get around some of the
hurdles we've had over the past 150
years
of commerce moving faster than money
you recently had a twitter thread about
separating state and money and you
compared it to the separation of church
and state uh decades ago
describe a little bit more about why
that is such an important idea right now
and why you think now is the time that
that could potentially happen
i think for the first time we have
credible technology to potentially make
it happen um i i don't think it's
guaranteed but i think it it it's a very
interesting kind of time to be in for
that concept uh you know if you go back
long enough the idea of of religion and
and government being separate would have
been considered odd um uh and it would
have been outside of the overton window
of discussion um but eventually that was
that was kind of separate you'd have
okay people have their religion then you
have government and it's not tied to any
one religion obviously the whole world
doesn't operate in that model but a
number of countries do now and when it
comes to separating state and money
people have a natural idea in their mind
that if there's a government they must
be the issuer of currency um that that's
an inherent thing that a government has
to do and i think as we saw i mean there
are some dollarized countries for
example there are small countries that
for one reason or another they don't
have their own currency maybe they maybe
they failed their currency so poorly
that it just got dollarized maybe it's
because of a decision they made there's
a couple you know there's a handful of
countries like this um and just even
ones that are not dollarized there's a
really poor track record when you look
around the world of most
government-issued currencies i mean the
the dollar and the swiss franc have been
like some of the best ones and even
those have have you know had their own
problems when we look globally uh it's a
huge problem and it is it's quite
possible that technology and adoption
will get to the point where it becomes
increasingly hard or
you know not ideal for governments to be
the issue of currency and you know i
think it would start at the periphery uh
you know the types of countries that are
dollarized now i think there could be
more of those that become you know
private monetized we can call it um and
that it could spread towards the core uh
but i think it's a trend to watch and
and to keep an open mind
about the role of government that that
you know separating money from state
doesn't mean anarchy just like
separating religion the state didn't
mean anarchy it just means a different
model and a different division of powers
when i think about these dollarized
nations uh they basically are having a
different country that is focused on a
different economy create the monetary
policy which affects their country and
so that you know it's pretty obvious how
that could be um difficult or not
necessarily ideal
but when it comes to countries that do
have their own nation-state currency
one aspect is
the single best position to be in would
be to control the global reserve
currency do you agree or disagree with
the statement that the second best
position to be in was for would be for
the world to use a non-nation-state
currency if you are not in control of
the nation-state currency
i guess they could describe it yeah if
you have the power to have the currents
that everyone else relies on that's
obviously the best place to be in uh
whereas the second best choice for
everyone uh is to use a kind of a a
neutral objective currency and then the
funny thing is even as the global
currency reserve issuer it's not like
everyone in that country benefits
equally some people are actually harmed
by the fact that others in their country
are issuing the global reserve currency
and so that that goes down to the whole
trip is dilemma uh that i've kind of
written about and talked about a lot
which is basically you know right now
for example the cost of the united
states maintaining its global reserve
currency is that we pretty much have to
run structural trade deficits to make
that work properly um and so that
obviously
it benefits you if you're near the
issuance of that currency if you work in
government wall street um if you're
in a very high margin business like
technology or healthcare you know you're
generally shielded or even benefiting
from that situation whereas if you make
physical things in the united states
you really get no benefit and maybe some
downside of being in the currency
reserve issuing country uh and so
the fall back for many people is is yes
uh you know kind of a separate neutral
currency but only if the technology is
there to make it possible i mean a lot
of the reason why gold was eventually
moved away is just because it was too
slow and it allowed for
policymakers to arbitrage that and get
people to use something that that
devalued and that they had more control
over
how do you think the transition would
occur so let's say you know uh this does
happen and we transition from a uh kind
of nation-state-led monetary policy or
currency to
a decentralized uh version of it or a
neutral uh kind of agnostic to any
nation
what does that look like is it kind of a
parallel adoption similar to maybe what
we're seeing in el salvador where
they're dollarized and they create
another legal tender and then they kind
of live with two for a while is there
countries that you would anticipate will
just kind of rip the band-aid off and
say hey you know on monday we're moving
and everyone get on board like how do
you see this playing out
i've used probably a parallel option
because i mean if you use bitcoin
example it's right now is too volatile
you know for a whole country just to use
that as their as their entire currency
so i think it'd be something that just
grows in parallel and and the longer it
lasts the longer the lindy effect goes
on um the more that organic adoption
occurs and then a couple countries
acknowledge it and maybe use that as
reserves maybe make it legal tender i
think it grows from there and again
there's no there's no guarantee of that
worldview happening it's just an
observation of the technology itself
what it's what makes it what's possible
what the risks are i think in a
pre-bitcoin world um i think eventually
probably gold would get some degree of
prominence back as a number of these
currencies failed i think that for
example gold would be more used in
reserves and that you'd have more like
you know gold as kind of the the neutral
currency that that various fiats get
kind of um you know either peg to again
or at least like you know that they that
they all float kind of against gold and
gold is kind of the core of the system
uh but now i think we have we have some
other alternatives like bitcoin that i
think are
you know have a shot at changing the way
that that financial systems work you
know 20 years from now
and so as you start to see this play out
obviously bitcoin appears right now to
be the most likely candidate to kind of
fill this role are there other aspects
technologies digital currencies that you
think could potentially fill this role
or is it just bitcoin and that's kind of
the one shot we have for kind of a
nation-state agnostic currency
so i don't really say anything other
than bitcoin that has the qualities to
be like a reserve asset or like a global
neutral money i mean there are i think i
categorize a lot of other things as
equities
i think some of them are doing
interesting things i think i mean for
example stable coins are something i've
been bullish on for a couple years now
um but they also serve like an
intermediate term role where it's a way
for people in different countries to
access dollars uh even if their local
banking system doesn't really want them
to or their local government doesn't
really want them to
because the stablecoin issuers are
centralized but the centralized hub is
outside of their country
and then due to technology they can they
can access these digital representations
of dollars
that are ostensibly collateralized
by pools of of assets um and so you know
i think that there are a number of
things here but yeah the only one i see
that actually can reserve that you know
i think that has
the the security of being like a global
reserve asset
is something like bitcoin
and as you look at kind of bitcoin and
crypto uh i think you've done a great
job of kind of highlighting the
differences where bitcoin is something
very separate and distinct
to the rest of the market talk a little
bit more about how you see uh the
differences in bitcoin and everything
else
so i think that a lot of other things
have some similarities to equities in
the sense that if you try to remove the
energy component you're basically
putting in more governance
a lot of them are more uh centralized uh
and so they end up looking like like
equity like like platforms that have
some degree of centralized development
uh you know a handful of stakeholders uh
that can kind of control the network uh
which which in my view is a lot
different than than what bitcoin does so
i think that
the way i generally categorize it for a
couple years now is that bitcoin is
money uh it's like a digital commodity
and a lot of else what we see in the
space is is kind of these hybrids or
these digital equities uh that that you
know might have value in their ecosystem
and as serving a purpose but they should
just be thought of uh rather differently
and when you start to look at a number
of these other areas
one of the kind of interesting ones that
doesn't seem to get labeled obviously as
bitcoin doesn't also get labeled as kind
of crypto is stable coins um they really
aren't trying to issue something new
they basically are just a digital token
that's backed one to one to dollars on
many platforms whether people want to
use them or not uh if you want to buy
bitcoin many times when you deposit fiat
in it sits in a stable coin and you have
to purchase bitcoin how do you look at
their role uh maybe just in like the
bitcoin and crypto ecosystem and then we
can talk about central bank digital
currencies
so stable coins are serving two
significant roles right now one is as
you point out unit of account for a lot
of trading platforms either either
centralized offshore exchanges uh or in
some of the d5 markets basically digital
representation of dollars it it's it's
still dollars it's just like you know
i'm going to talk about not talking
about the algorithmic variety but the
actual fiat collateralized variety those
are just dollars in in in this kind of
you know more efficient wrapper and the
second use case the one that actually
interested me more is you know people in
emerging markets or frontier markets in
countries with failing currencies uh you
know stable coins are useful for them to
to hold for kind of intermediate term
savings so let's i mean i had an
argentine and describe it to me very
well he's like you know
money that i'm gonna spend in under a
month i'll hold in local currency uh
money that i'm gonna hold for for
several months i'll hold in stable coins
and money that i want to would put away
for three to five years
i'll put some of that in bitcoin uh and
so i i think that there is
you know there's a demand for dollars
globally and stable coins just happen to
be the technology that it enables to get
allow them to get their hands on dollars
uh like i said before even if they're
even if they're governments and there's
and their uh banking networks are are
not making them available or trying to
restrict access um so i do think that
stable coins have that purpose this
decade um
and that's why i also think that there's
cool things like taro on lighting that
could potentially bring stable coins
over to bitcoin and it just becomes
whatever a network is most efficient to
transact those those dollars around
because those are less about pure
decentralization and more about what can
give people access to a cheap ability to
access that foreign central hub of
dollars central bank digital currencies
are
i think a whole another thing entirely
where
it's in many ways kind of the antithesis
of bitcoin those are more about
centralized control more about
programming restrictions on how to use
the money
and
kind of even pre-programming like
inflationary policy
and so
i think that there are some countries
like china that obviously are pursuing
the cbdc route pretty rapidly um and
then it's possible in the united states
do you see other other kind of public
private
you know partnerships maybe a stable
coin kind of gets treated as like a cbdc
because of course stable coins are
vulnerable to regulation and control and
regulatory capture
so i think over time those could
potentially merge more in some of these
countries that don't want to maybe
develop their own cbdc but i think it's
still very fluid
environment at this point and so it's
hard to sort of lay out a direct course
of how some of these things go yeah when
you start to look at uh maybe the
situation that we're here if we bring it
back to the united states uh it seems
like estimations are anywhere between
maybe 12 to 15 percent of american
citizens uh have some sort of
relationship or ownership of uh bitcoin
uh if you look at other places like in
uh nigeria self-reported is somewhere
over 30 percent i would handicap that
and probably say again probably 10 to 15
and so it seems in countries where there
is a decent amount of internet
penetration there are smartphones uh and
there is a reason whether for
speculation whether because of a
collapsing uh native currency
somewhere between 10 to 15 percent we
kind of hold that as like the adoption
level what would your expectation be
through the rest of this decade is this
like a 10 to 15 goes to like 80 to 90
percent do you expect it to maybe go 10
to 15 to 30 like how do you think about
kind of growth and adoption of an asset
like bitcoin given where we are in the
global macro environment
i i think i'm avoiding major tail risks
like a like a huge bug in the code or or
something like that i mean i think it's
going to trend towards higher double
digits
globally
globally
i think you could have different
adoption rates in say china versus
nigeria long term i think they can
maintain a pretty big difference there
in terms of adoption rates
but i think it's you know as long as it
continues to be successful and do what
it's supposed to do
i think it's you know over time it
becomes more widely held and then making
it more widely held
most likely makes a little bit less
volatile over time i mean it's still
going to be volatile for quite a long
period of time
but we do see very small amounts of
reduction in that volatility since the
beginning and i think if it was held by
you know five times more people 10 times
more people
that starts to get pretty significant
so right now i mean that double digit
percentage is not even in every country
right so it's it's like you said there's
countries with with high internet
penetration um countries that that for
whatever reason it spread there
culturally but less so in other
countries
for example we don't see it as much in
egypt as we see it in nigeria
and so i think that
kind of the low hanging fruit is that
we'll see low double-digit penetration
in most countries more countries
and then from there i think that some of
the countries that have these higher
penetration levels could go much higher
into the double digits
when you start to analyze uh kind of the
state of analysis around the current
financial environment it feels like
there is a bifurcation that's occurring
i'll call one uh the mainstream
consensus this is where you see uh
talking points from the white house you
know it's not a recession uh inflation
is transitory uh in those similar types
of phrasing and
kind of message and then you have what
i'll call like the internet and it feels
like those two
conversations or those two bodies of
knowledge are almost getting pulled in
opposite directions like like we're
getting more and more extremes and you
know recently the uh conversation around
what is a recession wikipedia has 30
plus revisions to it in a couple of days
uh just a blog post from the white house
is somehow the number one search result
almost immediately how do you start to
think about uh
maybe just the conversation about the
data versus the internet and what
appears to maybe be a little bit more
intellectually honest pursuit of like
what is happening
i think that goes back to the whole
fourth turning concept of of growing
distrust of institutions and kind of the
the gradual entropy that the gradual
decay of the the you know perceived
value of institutions and and the
usefulness of of institutions
and
that's why institutions get get those
cycles of destruction and being rebuilt
in a way that i think reflects you know
kind of the more modern era each time
and so right now i think that that
that representation of of how we're
being told to interpret weak economic
data how we're being told to interpret
inflation and then seeing very different
analysis online and elsewhere i think
that's a symptom of the era and that's
not to say that the online version is
totally accurate either i mean
misinformation can also spread very
quickly online and so i think it's
important for people to check sources
and and to do a lot of their own
analysis and to look for pockets of
credibility
but yeah in general i think that
crowdsourced kind of intelligence um
is is something that is really sniffing
out a lot of the the weakness in the
institutional narratives uh in this day
and age and it's something that is new
compared to the last time the world went
through this this kind of era uh you
know in the 1940s people couldn't send
her on memes of like the central bank
during yield curve control and qe and
you know and all the different things it
was doing there was you know it was a
much slower distribution of information
and so i think that that can make things
rather hard to predict and rather
non-linear as we try to figure out
what's going to happen the rest of this
decade
as we look forward over the next decade
what are like one or two things that
you're looking at or forward to that
maybe other people haven't put enough
importance on yet
i think
traditional markets still think this
energy inflation's transitory uh and i
think the under investment in in energy
capex is
gonna be one of the biggest themes of
this decade um
uh the heart of that right now is in
europe but i think it's it's large a
global problem and that's not just oil
and gas it's also like you know if you
want to have more ev penetration you
have to have better electrical grids
and it's about getting energy in all the
ways it's made to where it needs to be
nuclear is also i think a big component
of that conversation
and so i think energy security energy
abundance
are going to be like an ongoing issue
that you know even years from now i
think we're still going to be dealing
with and i think that that's under
appreciated and underpriced by
uh you know analysts that are not close
to the ground in terms of of uh kind of
the physical reality of the engineering
situation and the you know the complex
uh you know political situation all the
different factors that go into that uh
lack of capex
the last thing i want to talk to you
about is uh your process for producing
the research that you do uh
lynnaldon.com uh you put out these
monthly reports that are absolutely
fantastic they're incredibly robust and
and
i think what makes people so impressed
by them is not only the thoroughness of
the analysis but also your ability to
kind of articulate the ideas
so that people who much less smarter
than you can understand them
what is that process like and kind of
how do you put those together
usually what i do is i work on projects
in parallel
over the course of a long period of time
and so instead of just kind of like
working on one piece and then getting it
out like you know week by week
i really sit on each piece usually for
quite a while and i play with it and i
kind of sculpt it over time
um and i i shift back and forth towards
which whichever one is kind of drawing
my interest uh or that has a deadline
approaching and and you know kind of
move around like that and i think that
that
the amount of kind of um
you know if you spend one week full time
on something versus one month part-time
on something i think that the at least
at least the way my my mind works uh it
comes out better if i spent longer time
but part-time on it because
you know
your opinion can change in a week right
you might have like had us had an idea
that you thought was cool and then like
a couple days later you're like what did
i publish like like uh that's you know
that's not how i would write it today
but i think if you
really sit on something and play with it
for a while
it becomes a i think a better reflection
of what you think because you're
basically taking a longer sample size of
what you really think about something
and that allows it to be to be more true
by the time it's it's published
where can we send people if they want to
uh read those weekly or i'm sorry those
monthly uh research reports or if they
want to get the rest of the work that
you're putting out
so i'm at lyndon.com people can find me
there and i'm also active on twitter at
lynn alden contact
awesome my last question for you uh is a
little bit more of a fun one uh are you
having fun even though it's a bear
market in bitcoin and uh kind of as you
look around the world there's lots of uh
lots of issues i'm doing my best yeah
one thing i i i didn't do enough of over
the past couple years was exercise you
know there's the whole pandemic you know
gyms were closed and
uh you know i was overworked and one
thing i've been i've been really
focusing on in the past couple months is
making sure i'm getting outside more
getting exercise uh because then it
circles back and and makes me enjoy my
work more as well so i think people have
to have to find ways to be healthy and
to have fun even though we are going
through kind of you know just very
challenging times globally
that's an interesting point which is
what would your ideal day be like like
how would you structure it balance
between work and kind of exercise going
outside like what would that look like
um ideally pockets of both right so
instead of just doing nothing but work
for eight or ten hours and then getting
exercise is trying to mix it up trying
to you know go outside stretch your eyes
think about something you know if you if
you get up um you know do some work kind
of do your high impact work and then you
go out for like a long bike ride it
gives you time to think of what you just
did um so the time you maybe go back for
like your afternoon session um you know
you you kind of look at things from
another angle uh and so i like that that
kind of intermixing it together approach
yeah that's a great point uh i lied i
actually have one more question out of
personal curiosity what's the most
important book you think you've read
over the last couple of years whether
it's you know finance and investing
related or something else
probably lessons of history i might have
brought that up on probably my first or
second appearance in a show i think you
know it's like 100 pages that kind of
encompass like 5 000 years of human
history and trying to draw a couple big
conclusions or just big observations
from it um i think it's a pretty
important piece yeah you did mention
that one uh and i've read a piece of it
and uh it is it's pretty incredible um
awesome lin thank you so much i really
appreciate it you uh you continue to
be signal among the noise which is
greatly appreciated i know a lot of
folks in the uh
in the audience they subscribe to your
research and they really enjoy your
insights so thanks so much for all the
hard work and i will definitely do this
again in the future i appreciate that
thanks for having me all right sounds
good talk soon i hope that you enjoyed
this conversation with lin i learned a
ton from it and it made me think more
critically about where the world is
headed don't forget that these
conversations are brought to you by ftx
ftx not only has incredibly cheap fees
if you want to buy bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies sometimes as much as 85
cheaper than their competitors they also
have digital stock trading which allows
you to buy stocks and crypto in the same
exact mobile app
now that stock trading comes with no
transaction fees and no payment for
order flow so it gets you best pricing
ftx continues to push the pace of
innovation when it comes to financial
markets go check them out by clicking on
the link in the description and let me
know what you think about their service
in the comments